alors on va parler un peu des marchés
justement avec notre invité ce soir le
planificateur financier fabien major
bonsoir bonsoir
alors on sent on va parler de l'effet de
l'élection présidentielle sur la bourse
dans un instant et du lien entre les
deux mais je veux vous entendre sur
cette volatilité
ces inquiétudes sur les marchés la forte
hausse des 99 l'incertitude sur la
reprise
un commentaire sur les chutes jours
effectivement vous l'avez mentionné tous
les titres liés au tourisme ont chuté
fortement parce que les probabilités
d'un confinement strict ben c'est la
crainte des marchés et cette nervosité
était palpable aussi puisque le projet
de loi d'allègement budgétaires à
washington s'est assombri puis on ne
crois pas donc le projet va recevoir
l'aval des politiciens avant les
élections et si ça passe après ce serait
même très étonnant et puis pour faire
souffler les familles avant noël ce
serait quand même très bonne chose
alors c'est un peu la réaction du marché
avec les cas en hausse de jusqu'à quel
point l'élection américaine en cours la
campagne et influences démarche rit oui
l influence énormément puisque il ya
deux choses sur moi qui influence
beaucoup le marché en ce moment vous
avez accueilli deux premières places
puis la seconde c'est bien sur
l'incertitude qui entoure le résultat
final de l'élection et le fait que le
perdant
va-t-il de concéder facilement ou pas la
victoire à son opposant historiquement
et là on va voir ce que vous nous avez
préparé historiquement quelle partie
favorise la croissance des marchés la
croissance des marchés est intimement
liée au pib
parce que le pib c'est la démonstration
que la bourse a donc anticipé les
réactions économique à partir bien sûr
des politiques des partis est
historiquement on s'aperçoit que le pib
il augmente un peu plus avec les
démocrates on parle d'une moyenne
annuelle de 3.6 et en ce qui concerne
les républicains ces deux points 6 mai
ont pour sa de différence dans produit
intérieur brut d'une nation c'est quand
même énorme
est ce un pari sur les marchés boursiers
aussi le graphique qu'on voit c'est le
rendement de v s p500 pendant quarante
huit mois là
les républicains et les démocrates alors
aux bleus ce sont les démocrates
on voit que la ligne donne un meilleur
rendement finalement que les
républicains qui est en rouge là oui
exactement ce qu'on a sous les yeux donc
c'est un compte-rendu une analyse de
1928 à aujourd'hui avec des républicains
ou des démocrates qui sont à la
présidence et on s'aperçoit que pour
quatre ans la moyenne de rendement c'est
cette poussée de croissance durant trois
ans durant quatre ans et 33% et en ce
qui concerne les démocrates
la poussée de croissance atteint 71 2007
dont près de 72%
c'est plus fort c'est toute l'économie
oui c'est quand même tout un écart et on
s'aperçoit qu'une majorité des
récessions aux états unis ont eu lieu
sous l'ère républicaine ont reçu les
interprétations peuvent aller dans
toutes les directions
mais effectivement il se passe toutes
sortes de choses à toute sorte de moment
la plupart des présidents de toutes
façons vécu des récessions au fil du
temps mais je suis quand même
impressionné de voir l'écart entre les
démocrates les présidences des moteurs
délai présidence républicaine six mois
quand on a six mois après les élections
c'est assez juste et à peu près 4 5 % le
rendement des marchés
mais lorsqu'on a une année trois années
quatre années bella et un net avantage
vers les démocrates pourraient et ça
doit davantage vers la fin on l'a vu
dans le graphique
regardons un autre graphique maintenant
est ce que les marchés affichent un
meilleur rendement avec un nouveau
président se serait déjà joe biden
aujourd'hui ou avec un président réélu
qui serait donc donald trump
maintenant n'importe quoi même dans le
commerçant la saveur du mois le nouveau
et tout ça c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant et on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
pleins d'espoir les marchés boursiers
sont très émotifs et réagissent à
l'effet de nouveauté en ce qui concerne
les politiciens si vous avez un
politicien qui revient au pouvoir
en général le marché à une croissance de
10%
et au bout de quatre ans et 42 43 % le
rendement cumulatif pour un politicien
donc un second mandat un président qui a
été reporté au pouvoir comme obama lui
et comme trump le souhaite mais lorsque
historiquement de 1928 est aujourd'hui
on voit un
au président se pointer alors là au bout
d'une année le rendement de la bourse
ses 12 points 4 % au bout de trois ans
on à 38% et lorsque on a fait le 4 ans
et 62%
ici c'est tout pas me tue tous partis
confondus c'est donc l'effet de
nouveauté qui favorise les marchés et
qui favorise donc dubaï donne
aujourd'hui dans ce cas oui mais il ya
un autre élément qui favorise également
les démocrates en ce qui concerne la
bourse il ya beaucoup de statistiques là
dessus celle qui m'a impressionné le
plus moi c'est le rendement du dow jones
depuis 1900 avec un président démocrate
on a une moyenne de 7,8 pour ça et avec
un président républicain c'est 3,28 donc
moitié moins que plus de la moitié moins
alors c'est assez clair quand même le
lait les données que vous nous donnez
aujourd'hui si fabien major pour cette
analyse merci gérald bonne soirée